now I do want to give you some other
perspectives that existed on Fox News
after this just treacherous and
ridiculous press conference between
President Donald Trump and President
Vladimir Putin Hannity did it Hannity
had Trump on after the summit he
promoted Trump he said how strong Trump
was not everybody did though Neil Cavuto
from Fox News maybe he's think he's on
Fox News and Fox Business now Neil
Cavuto called it disgusting okay here's
an example of a Fox host who it was just
too much even for them to tolerate I'm
in the place this was the time in the
place for the president to look Putin's
squarely in the eye and said you will be
punished for what you did in 2016 and
don't ever think about doing that again
but he did and that's generated
disgusting that's what made his
performance disgusting I'm sorry it is
the only way I feel it's not a right or
let thing to me it's just wrong
a US president on Florence all talking
to our biggest enemy or adversary or
competitor right I don't know how we
define them these days is essentially
letting the guy get away with this and
not even you know offering a mild a mild
criticism that that that sets us back a
lot Neil Cavuto is right that it
shouldn't be left or right but it is
left or right because there are trumpets
who seem to find absolutely nothing
wrong with how that summit went bret
baier calling it surreal I get it
surreal is not a huge criticism but
still it's Bret Baier after all this is
almost equivalent to calling it treason
for a fox news host Brit Hume the senior
political analyst at Fox News saying
Trump finally asked whom he believes on
Russia interference gives a vague and
rambling non answer with renewed
complaints about Hillary's server says
he trusts US intelligence but made clear
he takes Putin's denial seriously lame
response to say the least and then even
during Hannity when Hannity's guests
started criticizing what took place
Hannity immediately interrupts and tries
to prevent CIA chief of station Daniel
Hoffman from explaining what he means
then another panelist
rise to say well why didn't Trump stand
up to Putin and very quickly Hannity
interrupts and lo and behold the segment
ends who have devoted your life to the
CIA and this ought to be something that
we get a handle of here's my point
Julian Assange was 17 years old and
hacked into NASA in the DoD it's 30
years later where is our cybersecurity
that prevents anybody from being able to
do something like that where is it at
some point we got to say what are we
doing that they can still do this I mean
I spent a good part of my life
collecting intelligence on Vladimir
Putin so let me just take a look at it
from from his eyes from the Kremlin and
that's why I believe that if the
President had said look Vladimir we know
you meddled in the election I'm not
asking if you did but I know you did and
if you continue to do it I may think he
didn't do that why didn't they have it
all and frank discussion i think he
didn't maybe he did it privately but i
think it would have been good to hold
him accountable publicly and let me just
finish real quick with my thought which
is so you issued what does that do to
our future relations what i'm gonna
embarrass you in the world never talk
again about nuclear proliferation syria
let me just finish my thought real quick
we have a multi-faceted relationship
with the russians going back in the
second world war we collaborated against
nazi germany right at the same time the
soviets were stealing our nuclear
secrets there's a lot of stuff that goes
on in where we collaborate and at the
same time that you're targeting us
aggressively and he needs a counter this
the style regime and he's a selector on
the right stage everybody should be
aware that even on Fox difficult to
suppress the most obvious criticisms of
how Donald Trump behaved during this
summit with Letterman Putin and it's
just not going to be tolerated
apparently by sean hannity and yeah this
is actually happening it's difficult
believed but this is what's going on and
if nothing changes in November at the
midterm elections the House and Senate
will be de facto complicit because they
are not going to hold Trump accountable
for this or for anything else and
meanwhile to round it out Rush
Limbaugh's commentary was that the real
threat is the American media which is
just about right
and very very dangerous stuff going on
like Putin is probably jealous of Trump
that he has FoxNews that he has Rush
Limbaugh right thank yeah I mean sure
Putin has RT but he has more not like
ideology they complement them in the
same way right no no no you should I've
been watching some we don't get it often
because it's got it's in Russian but I
am now with more frequency getting clips
from Russian tell it not RT TV but just
Russian television stations that are
broadcast in Russia and it is it's
glowing about Putin often times they
brag about how Putin has got trumped by
the whatever it's amazing actually
what's going on I don't think Putin's
jealous of that I think what Putin maybe
is more jealous of is that there's
enough bamboozle able people in the
United States that Trump could win like
if I were Putin I'd be thinking I've
gotten Russia to vote for me to the
extent that the elections are fair but I
actually kind of to kind of work for it
like I need to be a clever authoritarian
to actually get people to support me
Trump's a boneheaded fool and he still
was able to bamboozle people like Putin
probably wishes that he had the American
electorate to bamboozle rather than the
Russian people and there's a good case
we made that Trump was able to do that
but only with Putin's health yes yeah
and that's exactly what we hope to
figure out one of today's David Pakman
show sponsors is world crypto Khan it's
a three day event at the Aria Resort in
Las Vegas from October 31st to November
2nd this year's theme of world crypto
con is achieving mass adoption of
cryptocurrency and blockchain technology
specifically through small medium and
enterprise business innovation you can
join over 5,000 attendees check out the
hundred and fifty plus exhibitions
stretched out over two hundred thousand
square feet of meeting space enjoy a
full schedule of speakers including many
of the biggest names in the blockchain
world and the David Pakman show audience
can get a $300 discount on tickets by
using promo code Pakman at
world crypto con-com I've put a link in
the description under the video once
again that is promo code PA k ma n at
world crypto con-com